well as we enter monsoon season it's  important to remember  flash flood safety with yet another  chance for thunderstorms today officials  are asking us  to remind you to stay alert this is a  look at yesterday as storms fired up all  across the valley  when things look dicey public works  crews come out to make sure  people stay away from places like  detention basins and washes  in the event that there is a flash flood  desert breeze is another big one it's  got soccer fields it's  up on durango in the in spring valley  and gowan has dog runs and a great  walking trail  up in the northwest so we have multiple  facilities  that are used for both recreation and  flood control  every one of them is marked stay out  when it's raining  do not trespass this is a flood control  facility first and foremost now washes  are not supposed to have people  in them but as we have seen before it is  a place where some people do sleep  water in these areas can rush up to 30  miles an hour